because I grew up with them well this is
this is a great conversation topic
because I don't think sometimes people
understand when they say you know family
is important to me right
so I mean definitively what what do you
mean by family is important to you
it's family important to you in the
sense of just the family that you create
with the person that you're with are you
talking about everybody that's involved
because sometimes when we think about
relations when we get with somebody you
think that you're only with that person
but you're not the moment you get with
somebody you are also a part of their
family a part of their friends and you
may come a part of this web there
whether they've spun and they've created
prior to the prior to when you came in
so being in a relationship is a lot more
than just that single individual yeah I
agree
after your parents pass away even my mom
told me that I have to stick with my
life choices and the people that I'm
with but while my parents are here
because family is important to me and
this you know whatever how many years I
had been alive 32 years I've been alive
that I have this relationship with my
mom it's also very important to me to
it's also important in like when we have
kids right how important is it to me
that my kids can be able to communicate
with how many and how to write and they
can't speak Korean and then how many and
how do we just come to it and I see this
all the time with kids who don't know
how to speak to language when their
grandparents it's just are you hungry
yeah you want to play with toys yeah
that's it and it's so hard to watch
because they can't communicate with each
other why when my aunts met you
the first thing that they says you're
Korean he speak Korean they got so
excited I don't even think they cared
that I could that I was Korean as I
could speak Korean yeah I think that
threw them off yeah right it was more
like and it wasn't just and when people
say they speak Korean by the way like my
Korean isn't the best but I can have a
conversation like you you can understand
them hundred-percent
yeah it's just your cuz you're you're
used to listening but you're just not
used to speaking yeah you could totally
talk to them yeah I could speak it just
takes me a while to warm up because I
don't speak it as often anymore if I'm
talking to my mom on the phone and then
I talked to her parents after then it's
easier because it's already there but
what happens is it's like because it's
not in use I get caught up in in work
I'm like I should know this word like
why don't I know how to say this more
yeah but when I talk to our parents it's
super slow at first and as we speak in
to speak throughout the day it's
ourselves coming back yeah and then it
starts to get easier so it's all about
with that - like would I be able to
speak to your dad no your dad isn't
speak English talk to your mom your mom
speaks perfect English but then I
wouldn't be able to have a relationship
with your father and then I feel like
the big approval process that I have
with your family was because your aunt's
liked me so much
also because I look like one of their
sons my oldest cousin yeah what's so
interesting I know yeah so like I don't
know like I feel like that language part
is very important I just don't want my
culture to die I think that's the thing
I get scared about the most is like I
see people who they kind of disregard
the importance of culture a lot like I'm
not I don't feel a certain way if people
want to do that right but I do
appreciate when people choose to instill
a big part of who they are into their
into the generations that's that's ahead
of us so when you had this kid and yet
though we are here in America I want our
kids to be able to speak Korean I wanted
to like Korean food and I want them to
understand where they came from and why
I am the way that I am and who they are
and why they look the way that they look
it's because you are Korean there's a
huge part of who you are that's in your
blood that's I truly believe that it's
interesting cuz when I was growing up I
actually try to hide the fact that I was
Korean because I couldn't blend with my
Korean friends whether those Korean
friends in Korea or Korean American
friends here like I just couldn't
connect because I was so we have
something called a second generation
reign for Koreans yeah there's first
generation which is are usually our
parents and then second drainages us and
there are some of us out there we call
ourselves 1.75 yeah I'm first generation
your first generation no your second
your whole parents are first I wasn't
born here I was born in Korea right I
forgot I I got my citizenship when I was
like 23 I forgot about yeah yeah yeah oh
I'm I'm technically second every kid had
an Engel dude but because I lived in
Korea for a bit I had a hard time
figuring out who I should blend with but
I felt like none of the Koreans accepted
me for who I was so I had a lot of
resentment to Korean so in my during my
teens I pretended that I was not Korean
and people and it also
look Korean I look people a lot of
people ask me if I was Japanese I just
kind of absorb that but like yeah I
guess I am hmm
and kind of stay away from this Korean
culture culture until later on in my
life is when I really appreciate it how
much I I grew up with Korean culture and
just being experienced living in that
culture because I mean it's so useful
now you know I could there's so many
people out there who are very interested
and want to learn and also you know I
could utilize it with my aunts who can't
speak English I could utilize it with
your mom you know not that only know how
to speak Korean but then I also
understand the culture so I can
communicate you know really using their
language yeah I mean it's important like
I said because wait yeah because you
speak Korean like you're allowed to have
a relationship with my parents and our
relationship gets stronger too and once
again I'm just gonna reiterate this this
is just an opinion of mine you know if
you if you have a relationship and you
can't communicate with your in-laws and
you say that's fine that it's fine for
you but I do believe as a [ __ ] fact
just because I've I've had I've never
really been with a Korean girl besides
you and then milk girl before me before
you that it just wasn't possible you
know there was the nod that was the high
there was a smile but because they
couldn't speak to each other my mom
likes to talk she likes to get to know
people sure that's where the
relationship would have stopped she's a
very sweet girl that's it so that's one
of your core values that you want yeah
like what the court the huge over
looming you know core value is that
family is important right so like when
we get together I don't want that girl
just to be able to stay next to me and
then have me translate everything that's
going on oh my mom is asking that you're
hungry oh my mom's asking how is work
it's dumb because there will never be a
bond there if you're okay with that
you're you are but for me because I care
about the the family strength a lot with
generations before and after like I need
that language part to be there because
my mom can't speak English and my dad
can't lose beginners right so when I
asked you let's speak Korean so we